I will lend books to people but of
course the rule is don't do that unless
you never intend to see that book again
[Music]
the physical object of a book is almost
like a person I mean it has a spine and
has a backbone it has a face actually it
can sort of be your friend books record
the basic human experience like no other
medium can before there were books
ancient civilizations would record
things by notches on phones or rocks or
what have you the first book says we
know them originated in ancient Rome we
go by a term called the Codex where they
would have two heavy pieces of wood
which becomes the cover and then the
pages in between would then be stitched
along one side to make something that
was relatively easily transportable they
all had to completely be done by hand
which became the work of what we know as
a scribe and frankly they were luxury
items and then a printer named Johannes
Gutenberg in the mid 15th century
created the means to mass-produce the
book the modern printing press
it wasn't until then that there was any
kind of consumption of books by a large
audience what covers started to come
into use in the early nineteenth century
and they were called dust wrappers
usually he had advertising on them so
people would take them off and throw
them away it wasn't until the turn of
the 19th into the 20th century that book
jackets could be seen as interesting
design in and of themselves such that I
look at that and I think I want to read
that that interests me the physical book
itself represents both a technological
advance but also a piece of technology
in and of itself it delivered a user
interface that was unlike anything that
people had before and you could argue
that it's still the best way to deliver
that to an audience I believe that the
purpose of a physical book is to record
our existence and to leave it behind on
a shelf in a library in a home for
generations down the road to understand
where they came from the people went
through some of the same things that
they're going through and it's like a
dialogue that you have with the author I
think you have a much more human
relationship to a printed book than you
do to one that's on a screen people want
the experience of holding it of turning
the page of marking their progress in a
story and then you have of all things
the smell of a book fresh ink on paper
or the aging paper smell you don't
really get that from anything else the
book itself you know can't be turned off
with a switch it's a story that you can
hold in your hand and carry around with
you and that's part of what makes them
so valuable and I think will make them
valuable for for the duration a shelf of
books frankly is made to outlast you no
matter who you are
[Music]